اعلنت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه مقتل 30
جنديا روسيا واصابه 20 اخرين في قصف نفذته
قواتها على مواقع روسيه في مقاطعه لوغانس
مقر القياده وحده عسكريه روسيه اضافه الى
سبع شاحنات وعدد كبير من الاليات والذخائر
ومن جهه ثانيه قال حاكم دونتس الاوكراني
ان مدنيه قتل وصيه اخر في قصف روسي على
مدن وبلده مدن وبلدات في المقاطعه
على مركز الدفاع الاقليميه تابعه للسلطات
دونيتك الموليه لروسيا في شرق اوكرانيا
قال ان مدنيا واحدا على الاقل كتل وجرح
اربعه اخرون في قصف اوكرانيا
الشماليه والغربيه اضافتها الى مدن مكيفكا
ويافا
وبلده في محيط دونات
الروسيه
كان في حين تشهد مناطق غربيه مع ريكا
عنيفه
درغامي امين اهلا بك اخر التطورات على
مختلف الجبهات في الشرق والجنوب واي
تحركات للقوات الروسيه بعد انسحابها من
خيرز
زينه المعارك محتدمه هنا في غرب مدينه
دنياس تحديدا في محيط المطار القوات
المواليه لروسيا بعد ان كانت قد سيطرت على
بلدات من بينها اوبتني تحاول الان همم
الضغط على بلدات اخرى وهيدينها وايضا
بيسيطر عليها تفتح للقوات الروسيه الطريق
اللي هي التقدم نحو الضيف كما تقول افضيفك
هي مدينه استراتيجيه همم متاخمه لحدود
ايضا هناك تحركات متواصله اللي هي القوات
الروسيه في محور هناك تحاول ايضا اقتحام
هذه المدينه لكن المعارك ما زال تتركز على
الجهه الجنوبيه والشرقيه من تلك المدينه
لكن هناك تغيرات حدثت همم
24 ساعه الماضي همم
بعد ان شلنا الجيش الاوكراني هجوما اعترف
اموالنا لروسيا بسيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
على بلده مكيفكا
وسعيها للوصول الى الطريق الرابط بين
كريمينا وصفات همم في مقاطعه لوغاز بهذا
التغير الميداني تكون القوات الروسيه
مهدده بحسب مراقبين عسكريين بالفقدان احد
اهم خطوط الامداد في منطقه الشرق وتحديدا
في مقاطعه لوغانس اذا ما اقتربت او سيطرت
القوات الاوكرانيه على ذلك الطريق وسط
ايضا
اوكراني كما يقولون لروسيا على طول
البلدان المتاخمه لخط التماس سواء في جنوب
مقاطعه او في شمال المقاطعه الى الجنوب من
دنيا القوات المواليه لروسيا ما زالت ايضا
تواصل تقدمها باتجاه مدينه
في جبهه دولياسك نتحدث عن اضيفك الى جنوب
مارينكا والى الجنوب ايضا من دنياتك هناك
مدينه اونجليدارا التي كانت القوات
الروسيه قد سيطرت على بلده قريبه من هذه
المدينه وتحاول الان فتح جبهه جديده نحو
الجنوب في مصر عالي لابعاد القوات
الاوكرانيه من محيط مدينه دونيتك وهم
الذين لطالم اتهموا القوات الاوكرانيه
بقصف احياء المدنيه انطلاقا من تلك
المواقع
ان